Lima thank you so much uh for joining me
um I understand that you actually saw
Imran in prison yesterday so let me
start by asking you how is
he well he's uh he's keeping really well
I since well he's been in prison since
six months now and uh from the beginning
he said he feels he's come to a retreat
where he's had he has time to read books
he he's been studying the
Quran uh so he's quite organized with
his exercise and reading books and fact
I think one of our most stressful
situations occurs when we take books for
him and he's yesterday he said he's read
all of them so it creates a bit of a
crisis because we've got to find books
for him to read and his friends do send
him books but yesterday what we gave him
he Dre all of them so now we have a
little bit of a crisis es what kind of
conditions is he living in in
prison it's a very tiny cell he doesn't
really talk about it much and he's not
really bothered I doesn't bother him
he's uh he gets the food he asked for
which is not much he just wants yogurt
and fruit in the morning and he says he
takes his meal in the afternoon like a
his one meal is in the
afternoon uh because in the evening they
lock the cell when they close down at
6:30 or
7:00 um he says it's so cold that they
get into their blanket or the doway and
it's a quilt so he says you can't come
out after that so it's really cold so he
laughs about it he's um not he doesn't
take his conditions that much too hard
his one concern when the judge came was
that he gets one Pakistan television
station and a lot of uh entertainment
channels like about 10 entertainment
he's got a tiny television not very
happy with it no news so but other does
he get any any sport channels Al Lima
know he loves his
sport no he gets like soap operas he
doesn't watch them I can imagine he
doesn't watch that mean I've known Iman
since I was a a kid actually and used to
watch him play cricket here in England
uh he was a superstar cricketer he was a
you know known as a swashbuckling
handsome Daredevil uh beloved actually
by so many people he then of course
moved on into politics and became a
leader but now it's all been crashing
down around him many think he's the
victim of a political persecution but
just in the last week alone just to put
people who are not aware of what's been
going on uh perhaps outside of of
Pakistan last Tuesday Imam was jailed
for 10 years for leaking classified
documents last Wednesday he and his wife
Bushra were convicted of profiting from
State gifts and given 14year sentences
they were also both banned from holding
political office for 10 years um and
then on Saturday a Court ruled that
Imran and Bushra would get another seven
years for avoiding their marriage this
was a case brought by bu's ex husband um
saying that it was unislim and illegal
so you you put all this together and
there's a concerted effort clearly to
incarcerate Imran for a very long period
of time and and indeed his wife how do
you feel about that as his
sister well that's only uh three of the
cases yeah well that's 199 to go so he
was hoping that we cross a centuries and
the years they convict him for in the
next few days uh but listen I'm I mean
just the three cases they don't have
anything to stand on they were held in
the so what they're doing is they they
don't want to let him out they don't
want people to see him so what they do
is they take the whole Court into the
jail so the there's a court room now set
up in the community center and there's
one judge a few hours then another judge
and the third judge so they come in a
row and that's what the only Advantage
we've had is we were able to meet him in
jail during uh Court proceedings they
allow five family members in uh they had
to fight to get allow some of the media
in so when the media goes out of the
courtroom they are not allowed to take
his name and on the media channels they
cannot describe him one of the
mainstream media channels one of the
people who left uh well a journalist
from one of the main media he went and
described him on a vlog and they fired
him from the channel so it's like it's
it's not Imran Khan who scared appears
it is the people who've incarcerated him
who are really worried and they're not
worried from him because he's
incarcerated what they're worried about
is his following at the moment it's
going at 80% in the country so how do
you clamp down on 80% of the population
we are a country of 240 million people
so how do you take their right away
which is their right to vote and select
their own leaders so the whole issue is
not Imran Khan is the what he's done and
uh it's not um the prime ministership
that was ever important to Imran Khan
what was important to him was what he's
actually achieved if you ask me as his
sister maybe not as a sister but as what
we've seen him do he's
actually uh enlightened or he's mentored
a whole generation I would say a couple
of generations to
make them understand how important it is
for them to
have just access to Justice uh access to
education access to health and to stand
up for their rights so what he actually
has taught the Pakistani younger
generation is to stand up for their
rights and now in this election him
being in jail they understood and I'm
really proud of our pakistanis they did
not have Chaos on the streets they did
not Rite on the streets they have they
have basically weaponized what they call
a vote they've understood that the real
weapon in their hands for their own
freedom is the vote and what as the I
wouldn't say The Establishment but
whatever the powers that be which is a
tiny minority tiny minority all they're
trying to do is to steal their vote so
this whole exercise of what what we call
rigging is
stealing everybody's vote and please do
not forget that there are about maybe
120 million people under the age of 30
35 right very
huge and he also also he also Lima there
are two young men who have been very
vocal in their support and that's iman's
Sons uh suan and cim who tweeted a
picture um of them both holding a PTI
colored Pakistani flag ahead of the
election saying tomorrow this was on the
7th it's a huge day for Pakistan your
vote is important as soon as you're able
to please post a photo or video saying I
voted PTI with a hasht vote PTI to show
your support uh Pakistan zindabad um I
know is very close with his sons how
often is he able to to talk to them is
he allowed to make phone
calls I think I must have gone to court
I don't know maybe a dozen times
appealing to the judge to allow him to
speak to his sons and all and he's gone
in front of the judge several times to
allow him to speak to his sons I think
he's managed theyve after a lot of sort
of uh uh effort maybe he's spoken about
four times in the past six months that's
terrible the normal prisoners are
allowed to speak to their families every
weekend like on a SAT satday which is a
normal prisoner in in jail but not him
maybe averaging once a month or first
time he spoke to them was after four
months and he really wanted to speak to
the children and he's very happy when
he's spoken to them and the boys are
very happy when they've spoken to their
father and this Alma this comes you know
only just over a year after there was an
assassination attempt on your brother I
spoke to him shortly after that and he
was typical Imran you know dusting
himself down getting on with it not
going to be deterred but he kind of felt
that one day this might you know
somebody might be successful and and
kill him as his sister how do you how do
you feel about the fact that he's become
such a Target to extremists who want to
kill
him oh there are no extremists trying to
kill him that's that's not there's
there's no extremist killing him that
was how they wanted to Stage it it is
anybody who doesn't want him to uh
basically I I I mean I feel that he's
brought about a huge change in Pakistan
and this this change is people rising up
against the elite capture and he and
that everybody should be in under the
law not above the law he's been very
clear on that and the it was one was
when he was shot there were about two
snipers and one person on the ground who
who shot at this at his uh um rally but
then there was another attempt when they
barely made it out of the judicial
complex but they had snipers on the
rooftops they were going to shoot them
shoot at them that was about to be a
second attempt so it's not that it's uh
it's two attempts and in jail um maybe
we were worried about his safety in jail
like is he safe in jail will they poison
him so there's always a concern but I
think he's help all of us come through
the past few months and we feel well if
it's if you're going to die then uh um
it's going to be a big contribution
towards a cause because Imran Khan is no
longer as in they say in Pakistan he's
no longer a person he's a he's a
philosophy now and uh he's in jail he's
not standing for elections there's
nothing they will not allow a picture to
come out there's a they will will not
allow so I bring out he sort of tells
his lawyers or he tells us and I bring
out his messages so that's all people
get to hear and yet they are determined
to come out and vote and and so so they
get arrested the candidates are being
arrested they last night I think several
of them got abducted well many of the
top many of the Top members of the party
have been arrested family members you
yourself are facing charge that they've
leveled against you um you've been
accused of creating divisions between
the people and the Army by criminal
conspiracy and of anti-state speech uh
are you fearful yourself that you're
going to be
arrested um we I I think my sister and I
have about four terrorism charges on it
even the word terrorism become a bit of
a joke over here um it's U for 9th May
the the but that case is about to it's
already begun that trial has already
begun in jail but let me tell you about
the three cases that he's been convicted
on the first one the first one is uh
Donald Le an American official he sent a
message to General Baja who was the
chief of Army staff that uh it was
basically a warning that you'd better uh
make the no confidence if you make the
no confidence vot successful then we
will forgive you so a few a month later
imran's government was uh dislodged but
now so Imran Khan went out and told his
people that there's a there's a move
conspiracy to remove our government
while he was a prime minister that's his
duty that's the oath he's taken to tell
his people they voted him in now
he's been
charged for 10 years he's been charged
for 10 years for losing a piece of paper
they said you lost the cyer this is what
I'm hearing about so many people
connected you know his wife has been
jailed you have are facing charges I'm
told that even some of his domestic
staff have been jailed um apparently his
driver his cook in jail since May um
this seems like a systematic attack on
not just Iman but everybody around him
both in the party and family and who
work for him um my my nephew's in jail
he's been in jail for five months he's
in a military he's in a military uh
prison my my driver who took me to a
protest he drove me to a protest and he
left well he he spent eight months in
jail they they sort
of uh
threatened my son who's in construction
they threatened the contractors that if
you work with him uh we will finish off
your business then numl University you
know this is a charity not not a charity
it's like a huge project that was in
br's dream to build a knowledge city
like Oxford and we had a huge $25
million construction project that was
about to begin they obviously threatened
the contractors he's backed off so we
are living through this that's fine we
live through this how do you think it's
okay how do you think this is all going
to play out talk me through the next few
months about what you predict may happen
here well the preo Le rigging has been
massive everybody in Pakistan knows it
they threaten people they they abduct
people they've broken into people's
homes they've they've threatened them
with dire consequences to their
daughters to their wives so do
understand Pierce that there's a huge
amount of anger in Pakistan now this has
this is no longer about supporting Imran
Khan this has become u a determined
effort by a lot of young people through
social media they've threatened people
who are on social media they've they've
they they get calls they get calls when
they're overseas they they get calls if
they're in another country so this is
anger against a system which is decayed
this is a system and a script that comes
from the last century do you believe Al
that IM I do you believe that imram will
be able to get out of
prison um well he should be able to the
cases are
FAL do you think he will be able to beat
the system and get out or
not do you know the he has received
offers through various channels we've
received offers that if if you uh agree
to leave the country or if you remain
silent for a couple of years all the 202
cases will magically disappear I did
well if they feel that I've said
something incorrect what I did say was
that if you feel that 202 cases can
disappear magically then do we need a
Judicial
System Imran Khan says he'll face all
the cases would would IM would he ever
take a deal like that and leave Pakistan
or
not he of course he will not he he won't
take any such deal he hasn't six months
that's what that's why these sentences
are taking you know that's why they're
giving such ridiculous
sentences the second case I just want to
tell you about the 14 years uh the MBS u
u from Saudi
Arabia
yeah Muhammad uh Salman bin Salman he
gave a gift a personal gift to Imran
Khan's wife when they visited and U
Imran Khan deposited it in U in the
treasury so what the they they have a
law that once you deposit it they
evaluate it they price it and then you
pay 50% and you can claim your gift and
what was the gift so that's what they
must it was a necklace okay and do you
know what it was
worth well the the government agency
priced it at maybe
$125 or
$150,000 right so what they have claimed
is that you undervalued had the gift
undervalued and the actual value of the
gift is $20 million so you have to pay a
fine of $10 million and you are
sentenced to 14 years each so we did say
to my brother I said listen please send
the gift back to
uh Muhammad bin Sultan and ask him that
please take the gift back and at least
that should get you out of the 14 years
And1 million fine I'm not going to say
Le I mean rather like Iman himself
you're very flagma about what is going
on it would be something that Crush many
families but you're clearly made of
tough stuff as a family unit when you
saw Imran yesterday um I mean does he
have a message for the world if they're
watching this
interview well yesterday his message was
very clear he said the polling agents
have to guard the votes that people are
casting it is the it is the whole thing
is about protecting the vote of the
people I I think if you ask me what and
he said uh you once you've cast your
vote have a picnic outside the polling
station because you have to guard your
votes because that's when the last bit
of their one is preo rigging and then
there is the election day rigging so you
have to protect your vote all he's asked
for in the past one and a half year is
for elections that's all he asked for
hold an election and let whoever wins
take make the government he never asked
for anything else he never asked for
deals he never asked and who is supposed
to vote what they're stealing is not
Imran Khan anything to do with Imran
Khan you are basically trying to steal
the vote of the people andma when you
referenced that you were concerned about
him being potentially poisoned in prison
is that a fear that Imran has and is
there anything you can do to to protect
him from that
happening only Allah can protect him in
jail right now because um we he's he's
because he's not going to agree to any
deal they want to pressurize him leave
the country why should he leave the
country he said it many times why would
I leave my country you know when they
were when one of the judges was uh going
through that case it is really a FAS I
mean the lawyers were shocked they said
we've never seen anything like this ever
in our lives and the judges were under a
lot of pressure and we were told the
judge was threatened one of the judge
had told some somebody I'm getting
pressurized my son is under threat
they've threatened their families I mean
it's it's really gone too far yeah but
Imran Khan
Imran opened the newspaper he gets one
newspaper he opened the newspaper in
court put on his reading glasses and
started reading the newspaper and he
said why am I bothering to listen to
this case because it's I already know
the match is fixed and I they're going
to sentence me in any case it's okay
okay so let them collect me a
century of 100 years of imprisonment
ridiculous I've got to leave it there
thank you for joining me please when you
speak to him around next please send him
my very best tell him I'm thinking of
him I I've known him a long time like I
say I know uh jamr and I've met his sons
and I hope that this all resolves in a
in the proper way for you and that he
gets proper justice but I thank you for
joining me thank you very much
thank you thank you P thank you for
having
me